there's a very interesting side story
going on
given that we're talking about
coronavirus and florida and trump's
election
there's a side story that kind of pulls
together coronavirus
florida trump 2020 and more and the
story is about the 2020 republican
national convention which is now in
jeopardy
and more and more republicans are saying
i'm not going to florida
to a huge convention that doesn't seem
safe
at all and donald trump is now going to
have to balance
the risk of holding a mass event in one
of the global hot spots not just
national hot spots florida is a global
coronavirus hot spot trump would have to
say what are going to be the optics of
doing that
what happens if turnout is terrible
because that's also the other
side of this right now so to catch you
up the rnc
was supposed to be in north carolina
this summer north carolina's governor
said you can't do it at full capacity we
just can't given what's going on with
coronavirus
trump was upset he moved it to florida
instead
lunatic republican governor ron desantis
is like sure do whatever you want
the latest news is that many republicans
are saying they're not going to go
mitt romney's not going that's not a
huge surprise because he's been one of
the most vocal
anti-trump republicans right now but
other republicans are bailing as well
senators roy blunt and pat roberts said
no go
uh florida congressman francis rooney is
uh
increasingly looking like he's not going
to be there marco rubio
sounds to be on the fence he's a senator
from florida imagine
having an rnc in florida to nominate
trump
and one of the two senators from that
state doesn't go
senator john thune liz cheney there's a
lot of
republican elected officials who are
saying and it's not seeming like a good
idea
republican senator chuck grassley is a
question mark
now consider the hypocrisy of this given
that republicans want schools
reopened we had a hundred thousand
active cases in the country in uh march
april
and it was deemed too dangerous to go to
school so schools were closed we had a
hundred thousand cases
close it down we now have 1.8 million
active infections and republicans are
saying
open up the schools but i'm not going to
the convention that's way too dangerous
and these examples are very widespread
you know it's too dangerous for paul
manafort to be in prison
because of coronavirus but all schools
should reopen so this convention thing
could end up being a problem
at this point for donald trump no matter
what now we talk about self-inflicted
damage
he spent months saying the convention
will happen if it doesn't he looks weak
so that's potentially a problem for
donald trump
if he does the convention there's the
problem of spreading coronavirus in a
state
that is racked with one of the worst
outbreaks of coronavirus in the world if
florida were a country
it would have one of the worst
coronavirus outbreaks in the world
and if trump does it and the turnout is
low
he gets the bad optics of spreading
coronavirus
plus the bad optics of people not
showing up so once again
self-inflicted damage now meanwhile i
don't even care
about a democratic national convention i
mean listen i'm voting for biden
i i know what the right move is in
november i don't need a convention
i don't need debates it's just such a
clear
choice keep people safe and remove
donald trump in november
let's move on get biden inaugurated in
january hopefully we'll have better
functioning therapeutics
more production of monoclonal antibodies
convalescent plasma
maybe an early use vaccine hopefully
will start start to be available
uh from a circus standpoint of course i
would love to see the debates i would
love to see the convention
our live streams would do so well
streaming this stuff
but i don't want anybody getting sick
and dying even the sycophants that would
show up
to a convention in florida in the middle
of a pandemic
would be exactly the people that
wouldn't want to wear masks and would be
most likely to spread disease so
you know i i i would love to see
conventions
uh they're only every four years i would
love to see the debates but
the truth is we don't need them we all
know what the right thing to do is in
november now as a reminder
the real reason they want schools open
is not for education
it's not for the mental health of the
students it's they need the economy to
look normal many parents can't work if
their kids aren't in school that's
really at the crux
of it if you believe that your
re-election hinges
on things like things seeming normal you
want schools open
because so much depends on schools being
open putting cars back on the road
parents going to work business is
opening a lot of it is connected to the
daily routine
of parents getting their kids to school
that is
all that trump cares about if you care
about health you've got to look
elsewhere
you're not going to get anything health
based from this administration
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's
perfect if you don't have enough time to
do all the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video